and i was like all swollen underneath
the makeup
and it was turns out a trip to hawkins
isn't all sunshine and daisies
both on screen and behind the scenes
stranger things has had their fair share
of goriness and horror over the past
three seasons and while we may think
it looked epic on screen it's at the
expense of the cast
suffering through just as many hours in
the makeup department
as they do on set it's time to find out
just what would make the stranger things
cast
want to trade a day in prosthetics for a
trip to the upside down
instead i've been waiting to meet this
king steve everybody's been telling me
so much about both billy hargrove and
daker montgomery were put through the
ringer in season three
just in different ways with the mind
flayer on the loose and getting mixed up
with billy it resulted in plenty of
wounds
wounds that were all created by the
makeup and special effects department
there was no cgi or vfx for this
character
daker spent hours on end in the makeup
chair before heading to set
each day and when billy was at his worst
daker was sporting
33 prosthetics at once 33.
between him and his stunt double the
makeup team had to create and apply 99
prosthetics in one day
he was wearing so much glue that during
one of his lunch breaks his arm
prosthetics got stuck to the tablecloth
what made things even worse is millie
bobby brown's knee injury
actually caused the filming of daker
scenes to be pushed up with barely any
notice
the makeup department head amy l
forsythe said
i got a call during the hiatus giving me
a heads up about doing the post sauna
scene with billy on the stairwell
getting his wounds nursed the day
after we were to get back from hiatus i
hadn't even seen a preview for the sauna
fight so i didn't know how he was
getting hurt or where his wounds might
be
i gotta warn you again in your band for
life the duffer brothers were super
adamant about including as many
practical effects as they could in
stranger things
which means season one barely required
any digital visual effects
including the demogorgon the demogorgon
was actually just one big prosthetic
suit that was worn by actor mark steger
however opting for practical effects
came with some pretty big challenges for
mark
he had to perform some intense stunts in
the suit that he couldn't properly hear
or see in
but he did say that it helped him
remember why he loved film
in the later seasons the duffer brothers
eventually decided to move on to more of
a cgi route
let's just say things got a little too
gooey
it's crazy this is crazy this is crazy
daker loved being able to embrace billy
by adding on his
bad boy characteristics like his tattoo
and scar
however it was at the expense of
spending more time in the makeup chair
after a full day of filming daker would
endure another two
hours removing the prosthetics from his
body including the prosthetics he needed
to cover his facial hair
shadow he wore the prosthetic so much
that at one point he noticed his body
hair wasn't even growing back anymore
every day when you spend like two hours
getting them off like i remember there
was a big cut and scar
right here you can see i've got no hair
on my arm there because it's just been
months and months of shaving right in
that spot
it shouldn't have looked for me as much
as we all love steve harrington now
there was a time where him getting beat
up wasn't something we felt bad about
but you might feel bad for joe kiri when
you hear what he had to go through while
wearing these prosthetics
not only was joe sick on the day they
shot these scenes but he had to have
menthol blown in his eyes to achieve the
desired effects
ouch to be specific amy shared that his
prosthetics included a swollen jaw lump
cut split lip
and a mixture of cotton and dried blood
she shared her process on instagram and
even called joe
a trooper ahoy ladies i didn't see you
there
will's possession scene took a major
toll on noah schnapp
both mentally and physically not only
did he have to put himself in a dark
place but his costume consisted of black
contacts that made his eyes burn
his costume was also not designed for
the weather although it may have looked
like it was warm on screen
noah explains it was filmed in the
middle of winter there was just so much
going on
the heaters didn't actually heat up it
wasn't really hot
it was actually really cold because it
was winter
the cherry on top of it all was that
noah was so overworked and tired he woke
up the next day with
no voice i was screaming the whole night
and the next morning i woke up and my
voice had disappeared
movie makeup doesn't always mean gory
wounds and scars
sometimes the actors have a difficult
time wearing foundation
heaps of it nancy never really found
herself in a situation that led to an
injury but she did spend hours each day
in the makeup chair
it may not seem like it but natalie dyer
says she wore
so much makeup on set that she began
suffering from acne
the only solution was for her to amp up
her skincare game to prevent it from
getting any worse
we ask for forgiveness not permission
what the audience doesn't realize is
that prosthetics can sometimes minimize
an actor's senses
in this intense shower scene that daker
had to film he was so
physically involved that he was actually
injured without even realizing
he was only able to see the scrapes and
bruises that he accumulated on his body
after taking off the prosthetics he was
wearing just listen to him explain his
experience
i was covered head to toe in cuts and
bruises and i took all the skin off the
top of my toes and
one of stranger things goriest scenes
had to be when a mind flayer
literally hatches from eleven's leg
while the mind flayer in this scene was
digitally added
in post-production everything else about
the wound was done using makeup and
prosthetics
millie had the benefit of using a
prosthetic leg instead of her own
however it was still pretty gross to
work with but not gross enough to stop
her from taking an instagram selfie with
it it took
months of research from the makeup
department in order to make the leg and
wound look as realistic as possible
and it's safe to say they did a duffer
brother approved job
i could do it who knew how versatile lip
gloss could be
billy's flayed look was achieved by
applying layers and layers of mac
clear lip gloss all in all he had to
wear a layer of lip gloss
a layer of dirt and mud and then another
layer of lip gloss to seal it all
together
as you can imagine wearing lip gloss
wasn't the most comfortable experience
but daker said it worked better in the
scene that he wasn't constantly having
to be sprayed with water
all day to achieve the wet look just
look how big that lip gloss jar
is one of the things we've gathered from
going behind the scenes of stranger
things
is that millie bobby brown gives her all
into her character 11.
no matter the circumstances
filming her scenes in the voyage shook
her to her core literally
her wardrobe was not cut out for how
cold it was on set that day
especially because she was constantly
working with water the stranger things
art director said
the one thing you are missing is that it
was freezing cold on stage that day we
shot this
and millie was a real trooper splashing
around in the cold water
sfx tried to heat it but it was too
shallow to retain
any heat don't be afraid don't be afraid
when you think about who the duffer
brothers were inspired by steven
spielberg
stephen king and john carpenter it's no
surprise they went down the practical
effects route even if it was
uncomfortable for the stranger things
cast at times
in addition to all the prosthetics and
makeup they even used practical effects
to create a lot of the upside down set
and brutal battle scenes like bob's
demise
did we mention that will's body double
was so realistically made by the makeup
department that they were able to pull
off the ultimate prank on noah schnapp's
mom
the question is what's worse wearing
prosthetics and makeup
or fighting demogorgons after hearing
about how barb's actress shannon purser
had to eat
baby food for her pool scene and bob's
actor shawn aston had to continuously
put fake blood in his mouth
we are going with demogorgons all jokes
aside the stranger things cast truly
does give their all
into every single episode they film and
these behind the scenes moments spell it
out perfectly
which actor do you think had it worse
when it came to special effects
let us know below thanks for watching